hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so i have a big
announcement to make today guys i'm
gonna be live tomorrow 6 p.m pacific
time on jackson hunter's youtube channel
you can find the link in the description
of this video i'm sure you know this guy
he's making amazing content about amc
and jimmy so if you have not subscribed
to his channel yet please do it now and
please come tomorrow 6 p.m pacific time
to watch this live stream with him i
want you guys to like comment and give
this amazing dude the greeting he
deserves and thank you so much to paula
that helped to organize this meeting you
are the best so today i want to make an
analysis uh about amc as usual i'm more
gonna be focused on the short term uh
because tomorrow we're gonna discuss so
amc jamie we're gonna discuss the
targets we're gonna discuss what can
happen if there is a squeeze how likely
is the squeeze to happen everything so
today once again i'm gonna more focus on
the short term so let's get into it
[Music]
and yes so very quickly i just remind
you uh my target that is unchanged once
again we're gonna discuss this tomorrow
uh on jackson hunter's youtube channel
but as you guys know i apply fibs uh so
first wave second wave third wave force
waves i apply fields i use elliott wave
theory that says that usually when the
fifth wave is extended in this situation
it's equal to 1.618 times one plus three
so here it would give us a target one
around 140 and 35 to the it depends
where you start the first wave but it's
not going to change much the area is
around 130. so we're going to discuss
once again how likely is this to happen
and if it can go higher their answer is
of course yes but we're gonna see that
tomorrow so here
let me make the analysis about what is
gonna happen in the short term so we had
this breakout all right the same way we
had uh the one before that was the end
of the second corrective wave and this
for the same reasons this breakout is
for me the signal that the force
corrective wave that is coming from 73
down to 28 29 is over as well so from
there we can expect a five waves move on
the upside so what did we have for now
we had to me what looks uh to be a first
wave i can break down this wave into
five waves as well one two three four
and five and you can see that here we
have this bearish divergence at the end
of the fifth wave that is signaling that
the market is out of steam that the
highs are not as powerful as they used
to be uh just before so this is a weak
signal that got followed by a correction
so let's analyze this correction and
let's see what information we can get
from it first let's see how deep this
correction was so to do that i use fib
retracements and you can see them
that we went
roughly to the 61.8 percent so 37.7 38
retracement of the first wave so once
again if we have a look at the book
second waves usually are equal to 0.618
times the first wave so it looks for me
like a typical correction what i didn't
really like about this correction and i
told you guys this was that you know
fibs give you areas okay
but the real support and resistance
levels are actually defined by trend
lines and here you can see that the
bottom of the force which is a typical
area of correction for the second wave
is at 40. so i didn't like this okay
this is what we can call a fake out all
right this got probably uh many traders
out
of this trade and this is maybe the
purpose of uh those you know trading
algorithms that are running and i just
try to push some investors to the edge
and you know make them just close the
position at the
worst time so i'm sure that apes holds
but as you guys know there are many
investors implied in the amc trade and
i'm pretty sure that you know those
algorithm they know what they do and
here this breakout was to me not nice
but it's what we can consider as some
access it happens all right we didn't
stay there long you can see on the daily
time frame we had one close below and
then we immediately the day after closed
above so we never had the confirmation
of this breakout the confirmation is
whenever you have two consecutive
candles that are closing below the level
this didn't happen it's still a fake out
to me let's go back on the first time
frame so here what are we looking for
guys we are looking for the end of this
second wave in the same way here you
know the second wave
finished here so it's not as clean as it
is uh here i mean you can see that
everything is bigger right so this might
be good news as well it might take maybe
more time this move took like roughly
one month so maybe we're gonna take two
or three months but we already started
with you can see what seems to be a very
long
first wave so this is rather good news i
would say and we are waiting for the
short-term breakout guys okay this would
be for me the signal that the second
corrective wave is over so we are
waiting for something like this
okay bam bam and bam okay this is a
typical uh breakout situation so
breakout re-test and then we go higher
just like we did here but you can see
that sometimes the breakout is not
retested here we just moved higher and
never came back so let's see how this
happens here
it's going to depend a lot as well on
the global market as you guys know we
are still in the uncertain situation we
don't know if everyone is going to
default or not we don't know the impact
this could have on margin requirements
that hedge funds are facing to hold the
short positions so this can create some
troubles in the market i don't know
which way it would go but that's why i'm
monitoring those kind of short-term
signals that are gonna be helping us to
uh find what the market is likely to do
so this is what we're looking for and if
this happens once again we're gonna
discuss this tomorrow on jackson
hunter's youtube channel but what we're
gonna be really really looking at is how
high this third wave might go because
the higher it goes
then we're gonna apply the same method
all right as usual guys you know that
we measure from one to three so let's
say the third wave only go to uh goes to
73 and then the false corrective waves
goes back to 55 something like this then
it's going to give us a fifth wave
target at
125 roughly so same area but if the
third wave goes much higher and the
force wave corrects less which is going
to be making sense to me something like
this for example
then the target would be different so
for now i'm not changing my target then
we could reach maybe 240 and if there is
a real squeeze we're gonna once again
discuss this tomorrow uh so i'm not
gonna give you here all the different
scenarios but it might as well go higher
so let's see what is the highest target
we could have for a squeeze uh tomorrow
i'm gonna give that answer of course
it's only my view but i think that it's
interesting to look at what happened in
the past and just assume the same things
might happen again so that's it uh for
the technical analysis uh now let's
check what is the synthetic short
interest so once again guys uh for those
who don't know the spreadsheet i'm here
retrieving all the option of an interest
from the market all right so i'm having
all the maturities uh first of october
15th of october so on and so forth until
gen 23 i take all the options i compute
the delta okay so the delta is just
black shows formula as you can see here
guys so you can find it on the internet
if you want to do it yourself you need
the volatility though so it's not easy i
get it from bloomberg so if you guys
have a way to find the volatility you
can do it as well otherwise it's going
to be complicated to get the synthetic
short exposure but you can still uh have
the number of shares which is very
interesting okay which is the yellow
curve here this one is the number of
shares so you can see that we have a
huge concentration around 135 strike
which is totally unusual as you guys
know for the option market that is
usually concentrated around the money so
this is what is creating the gamma this
is what is going to create some bullish
momentum if we start to move higher so
we can see where this gamma is coming
from so of course 135 but we also have
some big exposure on the 40 strike and
the 60 70 strike as well so let's see
where this is coming from because the
shorter the maturity the more explosive
it can be so i'm looking here for the
greens as usual so gen 22 we have the
big one here we have a big one as well
and in october we have some big ones so
here those two are going to create a lot
of trouble so it's like very short-term
maturity you can see first of october oh
this one is going to create a lot of
trouble as well so let me give you an
example for example on the 1st of
october maturity
we have 14 000 options on the 70 strike
okay the delta is 4
at the moment so if amc goes higher so
let's say i don't know goes to 160
look at the delta it goes from four
percent to of course hundred percent
okay so it means that market makers uh
and the synthetic short exposure goes
from six to fourteen so it means that
market makers needs to buy uh roughly 10
of the share float on that day which is
uh the reason uh for a squeeze to happen
which is creating this bullish momentum
so we still have uh everything on the
option market that is going to create
this strong moves up if we start to move
higher uh but once again we need to
reach some levels for this mechanisms to
start being at play so here once again
the 4d strike you know you can see so 20
is not going to give us gamma and here
the 4d strike is mostly coming from gen
22 so the delta is already 66 percent so
this is not creating gamma okay so we
don't have that much gamma around the 40
strike but we have gamma around the 50
strike and the 70 strike so and so here
you can see bam
bam so those are short maturities and
it's like high strikes that have a small
delta 18
14 and four percent and this is uh the
reason for market makers to buy a lot of
shares on the move up so once again it
starts at 50. so amc needs to go close
to 50 or above 50 to start having those
strong moves up so in terms of charts
it's like roughly close to the highest
level uh we had in the past month so it
can happen very quickly so maybe the
third wave is gonna start this week uh
once again i'm gonna monitor that i'm
gonna let you know guys everything that
happens that i see and let's find out
what's gonna happen so that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore i see you guys